it is said that in a good film the music
score should go unnoticed I'm sure it
wasn't a composer who said it these are
the artists who are being noticed
tonight for painting the sonic pictures
that enhanced these fine films the
nominees for original score are Alan
Menken for Aladdin Jerry Goldsmith for
Basic Instinct John Barry for Chaplin
Richard Robbins for Howards End mark
isham for a river runs through it and
the Oscar goes to Alan Menken for
Aladdin
I've been very fortunate to work with
the studio like Disney that really
values music and that Adam who starts at
the top and I want to thank Jeffrey
Katzenberg and Roy Disney and Michael
Eisner for making my work possible
Aladdin was a major transition for me
for my longtime collaborator and friend
Howard Ashman to a new role in new
songwriting partner and Tim Rice as
always I was blessed with great support
my music team Danny troop and David
Friedman from Chris Montana Andy Hill
Bruce Botnick Michael Farrow and Cathy
Bennett from Peter Schneider John Musker
Ron Clements Amy Pell and Donner and
just I was dead of thanks to all of them
and to the brilliant animators musicians
singers and actors who made Aladdin so
spectacular and magical scott chuck had
my family my wife janice and anna Nora
my love and thanks and to the members of
the Academy thank you very very much